♪♪
>> Greg: YES!
MORE CONFUSION OVER MASK
MANDATES.
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS SAID THEY
WERE CAUGHT OFF GUARD BY THE
CDC'S CHANGE TO THE RULES LAST
WEEK.
BIG BUSINESSES ARE SPLIT ON WHAT
TO DO ABOUT PEOPLE COVERING
THEIR FACES.
FORMER SURGEON GENERAL JEROME
ADAMS SAID BIDEN SCREWED THINGS
UP.
>> THE CDC MADE THE RIGHT PLAY
CALL.
BUT THEY FUMBLED THE BALL AT THE
1 YARD LINE.
THE COMMUNICATION WAS JUST QUITE
FRANKLY ABYSMAL ON THIS.
WE WERE COMPLETELY BLIND-SIDED
BY THIS.
THERE WAS NO NUANCE.
YOU GOT WHIPLASH FROM LAST WEEK
TO THIS WEEK.
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE IMPROVEMENT
IN COMMUNICATION.
THE SCIENCE IS SOUND.
>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN NOT
HELPING TO CLEAR UP THE
CONFUSION.
>> ONLY THOSE THAT ARE NOT
VACCINATED WILL END UP PAYING
THE PRICE.
THE VACCINATED WILL CONTINUE TO
BE PROTECTED AGAINST SEVERE
ILLNESSES BUT OTHERS MAY NOT BE
IF YOU'RE NOT VACCINATED.
SOME PEOPLE MAY WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WEAR MASKS.
EVEN IF THEY'RE FULLY
VACCINATED.
THAT'S A DECISION THAT THEY CAN
MAKE.
SOME BUSINESSES MAY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO REQUIRE WEAR MASKS.
LET'S BE KIND AND RESPECTFUL AS
WE COME OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Greg: JUAN, I LISTENED TO
THAT -- TURN OFF YOUR PHONE,
DAGEN!
[LAUGHTER]
ALL RIGHT.
LIKE WHEN YOU LISTEN TO BIDEN,
THERE'S LIKE HEY, DO IT IF YOU
WANT, DO IT IF YOU DON'T WANT.
WE'VE SAID THIS BEFORE, IT'S UP
TO AMERICANS TO LEAD BECAUSE WE
CANNOT BE SUED, WE CANNOT BE
CANCELLED.
IS IT TIME, JUAN, TO START
BURNING OUR MASKS LIKE THEY
BURNED BRAS IN THE 1960s?
>> Juan: I'M TRYING TO MAKE --
WE CAN'T BE SUED, SO WHY
SHOULD -- I'M CONFUSED -- WHY
DID YOU SAY THAT?
>> Greg: CORPORATIONS ARE
WORRIED MORE ABOUT COVERING
THEIR BUTTS THEIR FACES.
SCORE.
>> Juan: OKAY.
I GOT IT NOW.
FROM WHAT I SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE STILL CONCERNED EVEN THOUGH
THE CDC GUIDANCE CAME OUT.
PEOPLE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PROTECTING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
I CAN UNDERSTAND IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOOD NEWS TODAY
IN THE LITTLE BIT THAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM BIDEN, HE SAID THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME NOW, YOU
KNOW, THE CASES -- INFECTION
RATES ARE DOWN IN ALL 50 STATES.
VACCINATIONS HE SAID WERE AT 60%
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AT LEAST ONE SHOT.
THAT IS FANTASTIC.
I THINK THAT IS EVIDENCE THAT
WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS.
SO I MEAN, I HEARD -- I HEAR THE
CRITICS SAYING WHY ISN'T BIDEN
TELLING PEOPLE THAT THEY CAN DO
WITHOUT THE MASK IF THEY'RE
VACCINATED?
HE'S BEEN SLOW TO TELL US TO
TAKE OFF THE MASK.
NOW PEOPLE SAY HEY, I THINK HE
WAS TOO FAST TO TELL US TO TAKE
OFF THE MASK.
SO AT SOME POINT HEY, MAYBE THIS
IS JUST POLITICS.
I'M GETTING DIZZY TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF WHAT THE CRITICS ARE
SAYING.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW, DAGEN.
I HAVEN'T HEARD A PERSON SAID
HE'S BEEN TOO FAST WITH
ANYTHING.
WE PREDICTED THIS BEFORE.
>> Dagen: THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
>> Greg: ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, YEAH.
THE SPOKESPERSON FOR PEPPERIDGE
FARM GOLDFISH IS RIGHT ON THAT
ONE.
DAGEN, WE PREDICTED ANY TIME
THERE'S A SURGE OR SURPRISE
CASE, THE MEDIA WILL KICK INTO
THEIR FEAR MONGERING, PROFIT
MODELS LIKE BILL MAHER HAS BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH COVID AFTER HE
GOT THE TEST.
THAT'S GOT EVERYBODY SCARED THAT
GOT THE VACCINE.
WE'RE ALWAYS GOING TO GO THROUGH
THIS.
>> Dagen: I IGNORE ANY STORY
LIKE BILL MAHER.
I IGNORE IT LIKE I DO HIS SHOW.
I HOPE HE'S OKAY.
SURE HE IS.
HE'S VACCINATED, CORRECT?
THE DEMOCRAT GOVERNORS AND LORI
LIGHTFOOT WAS NOT HAPPY WITH
THIS MESS OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY WEREN'T CONSULTED AND
STARTING TO LOSE THAT KIND OF
CONTROL AND POWER THAT AT LEAST
SOME OF IT THAT THEY'VE
ACCUMULATED IN THE LAST YEAR.
SOME OF THESE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS THAT ARE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE ANNOUNCEMENT OUT OF
LIKE OH, IT'S TOO FAST.
STOP WHINING.
YOU SHUT DOWN AN ECONOMY, A
STATE OVERNIGHT.
THIS IS SIMPLE RECOMMENDATIONS.
IT'S MASK ON, NOW MASK OFF.
BE NIMBLE ABOUT IT.
BY THE WAY, CALIFORNIA IS TAKING
A MONTH TO IMPLEMENT THIS MASK
GUIDANCE, THE CDC GUIDELINES.
SO I GUESS THAT IS BASED ON HOW
LONG PEOPLE STILL WORE THOSE I'M
WITH HER T-SHIRTS.
>> Greg: YES, I STILL HAVE MINE.
REMEMBER, I GOT ONE.
I GOT ONE IN OHIO.
IT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
DANA, IS IT THE -- ARE PEOPLE
HIDING BEHIND THIS ABUNDANCE OF
CAUTION WHEN IT'S AN ABUNDANCE
OF FEAR WHEN IT'S LITIGATION?
>> Dana: YEAH.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
LIABILITY PROTECTION FOR A LONG
TIME.
BASICALLY THESE COMPANIES, IF
YOU -- IN A WAY, IF THEY WERE
WAITING FOR THE CDC TO SAY THAT
IF YOU'RE VACCINATED, YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS ANYMORE.
SO THAT ACTUALLY I DO THINK
GIVES SOME COMPANIES LIKE THE
ONES THAT WE PUT UP ON THE BOARD
TARGET MAKING THE DECISION TODAY
TO SAY OKAY, THE CDC SAID THIS.
THE CRITICISM ABOUT THE CDC AND
THE MOVING TOO FAST IS COMING
FROM THE LEFT, FROM THE
SCIENTISTS.
EVEN THOUGH I KNOW DAGEN, YOU'RE
RIGHT, SOME OF THE GOVERNORS
WERE COMPLAINING ABOUT THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE GOVERNMENT IS SAYING
BUSINESS, YOU LAND THIS PLANE.
YOU FIGURE IT OUT FOR US.
THAT MIGHT BE OKAY.
I THINK THE ONE THING THAT I
REALLY LIKE TO GET SOME ANSWERS
ON IS JUST LAST WEEK, RACHELLE
WALENSKY, THE HEAD OF THE CDC
TESTIFIES IN FRONT OF CONGRESS.
THEY'RE GRILLING HER ABOUT THE
MASK MANDATES.
SHE'S JUST STALWART.
WE NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
THEN WEDNESDAY NIGHT THEY TELL
THE WHITE HOUSE IT'S OKAY NOW?
THEN THEY TELL -- WAIT TILL
THURSDAY MORNING TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT AND HE ROLLS THIS OUT
AT 1:00 THURSDAY.
TO ME, THE SCIENCE DIDN'T CHANGE
IN THE LAST FOUR DAYS.
WHAT CHANGED IS THE POLITICAL
WINDS.
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT -- I'M NOT
AGAINST THE DECISION THAT THEY
MADE OR THE ANNOUNCEMENT.
BUT WE SHOULD BE HONEST ABOUT
WHAT CHANGED HERE.
TO ME IT WAS THE POLITICS.
>> Greg: JESSE, DON'T YOU FIND
IT STRANGE THAT YOU CAN NEVER
PREDICT A POLITICAL ISSUE THAT
BECOMES KIND OF LIKE A
PHENOMENON?
THE FACT THAT THE MASK IS A
FOCAL POINT THAT CREATES SO MANY
DIFFERENT -- TWO FACTIONS WITH
SOME OTHER ONES IN BETWEEN.
IT IS INTERESTING THAT IT
BECOMES MORE OF A SYMBOL.
IT'S NOT A POLITICAL SYMBOL.
IT'S INDIVIDUAL FREEDOMS.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE COUNTRY IS SCARED OR
CONFUSED.
HERE'S WHY.
I WENT TO A WEDDING IN
NASHVILLE.
YOU GET ON THE PLANE.
THE COCKPIT TELLS YOU TO KEEP
THE MASK ON.
THE STEWARDESS FEEDING FOOD AND
BEVERAGE SO HALF OF THE PLANE
HAS THEIR MASK ON.
THEN YOU CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL.
YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM AND
GRINDING ON SOMEONE TO GET IN
THE AISLE SEAT BUT YOU CAN'T
DANCE.
I GET DOWN THERE AND VANDERBILT
IS HAVING COLLEGE GRADUATION.
THEY KNOW THE TRANSMISSION IS
NOTHING OUTSIDE.
THE COLLEGE PRESIDENT IS
VACCINATED.
THE STUDENTS DOUBLE MASK BROAD
DAYLIGHT, GET UP THERE, WAVE AND
THEN THEY MAIL THEM THEIR
DIPLOMAS IN THE MAIL.
ON THE WAY HOME, I GO THROUGH
SECURITY.
I HAVE TO TAKE MY SHOES OFF.
BECAUSE THE SHOE BOMBER.
REALLY?
THEY PULL ME ASIDE FOR
ADDITIONAL SCREENING.
THEY WIPE ME DOWN TO SEE IF I
HAVE EXPLOSIVE RESIDUE ON MY
HANDS.
LIKE I JIHAD JESSE OR SOMETHING.
YOU CAN CROSS THE CERTAIN BORDER
AND THEY WILL BUY YOU A BUS
TICKET TO NEW YORK.
SO I GET TO NEW YORK, I TURN ON
THE NEWS.
THERE'S LIKE A SLASHING SPREE ON
THE SUBWAY.
CUOMO SAYS HEY, DON'T FORGET TO
WEAR A MASK ON THE SUBWAY.
HE'S JAILING PEOPLE FOR NOT
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND TOUCHING
EVERY GIRL HE SEES.
HIS PARTNER IN CRIME, BILL
de BLASIO IS BRIBING PEOPLE TO
GET VAXED WITH FAST FOOD.
OBESITY IS THE NUMBER ONE THING
TO GET THE CORONAVIRUS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
SO YOU HAVE PEOPLE CONFUSED OR
SCARED AND POLITICIANS PIT YOU
AGAINST EACH OTHER TO WIN
ELECTIONS.
>> Dana: CRAIG, IN TSA'S
DEFENSE, JESSE LOOKED ROUGH
MONDAY MORNING WITH THE GLASSES
AN